what's up army yeah it's your generals
here yeah leading the way to go watch
some more BTS videos
BTS speaking English compilation this is
a top of warranty or video requests from
a woman named Nathalie Doran a Nathalie
how are you how are you how's Ireland
how's the hospice care this like
Leonardo DiCaprio voice you doing oh
damn I didn't know I could do that hey
before we go into this though I did want
to mention that over at our patreon page
we do weekly Q&A is TV show reaction
stream along as many of those shows have
reaction highlights included if you
don't want to stream the whole thing but
John actually does music video reactions
weekly this is true actually just did
the BTS comeback trailer for the shadow
interlude and if you keep an eye out on
the patreon Black Swan will be up as
well keep it right up to date with the
BTS uncut music video reactions and he's
got more to come whole bunch more
that's me - that's me - I relate
[Music]
ha
here's your dirty water hella did it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah is you when I look at neck motion
yeah yeah yeah good man it's a good
endorsement yeah you're all good you're
all gods they're all gods
[Music]
it tracks that's not lame I bet he's
gained super chats on YouTube that's
right that's how they blew up Coolio
don't stare him down
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
hahaha yeah you love it that's not a
great yeah
Oh
replacements card
[Music]
I got you are they writing on a regular
plane maybe this is like a super
futuristic South Korean plan that
reporters like I do you might need a
question answered
yeah
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
believe in you has a great selfie that's
a great so I hate seafood guys got such
cool voice you are it's right where you
want to be late I couldn't yourself that
was a skip edit or no no that's inciting
gun violence not cool not cool guys not
being sincere
yo wassup rapmonster
I love it it's getting better it's
getting better getting a little less New
York cab yes
BTS yo okay I don't know exactly how he
does it all we need to do is such a cool
boys it's a little bit raspy down Q he
has a punch every time yeah because he's
the most confident William best ladies
lady we down a date tonight that's all
that all right friends and harrypotter
that's how he got so yeah you're
absolutely
let me see y'all on the dance though my
name is rap monster
what is he running like a disco I had it
for like a split second and then I
quickly went down it what you need is a
prolonged video of just right it's like
if I watch a Nicolas Cage movie then I
can get Nicolas Cage there's a whole
video of just him this voice is deep but
it's not too deep and it's a little bit
of a rasp and out of that raspy so
somewhere down here then I don't do
generic black guy DJ for the seventies
this is what I have morphing into and I
do it he does seem to have the deepest
smokiest voice I have the BTS clan like
everybody else is a little more upper
register I feel like I have a theory I
think I have a solid theory ooh and I
think the army will agree with me on
this definitely RM remains the leader
always will be because he doesn't want
the rest of the members to perfectly
speak English he knows he can stay
constantly number one in the position of
BTS because he's the only one who could
speak English fluently mm-hmm damn he's
not telling that to them I think he's
gonna try to do things on camera or he's
encouraging them to speak English we
might even make jokes about the way
they're speaking English or what they're
saying poking fun at them because the
thing that all
keep him number one in the group is the
fact that he can speak English because
he's always the person when they go
traveling who can lead all the
interviews and stuff I mean it has
nothing to do with like him starting the
group or the history is none of that
it's because of speaking English
guarantee it
take this comment completely serious
please this is not a joke this is not
sarcasm I am NOT making fun of BTS or RM
100% genuine right here well from what I
read about this video in the intricate
storyline that you know is going on
underneath it apparently all the English
words that are M taught the rest of the
members he taught them that they mean
different things so even though it seems
like they're saying things to us in this
video actually they are under the
impression they're saying something
totally different it's actually like a
social experiment you know in
communication that's the smart thing to
do now to clarify I am just messing with
you
I am NOT there you go there you go we're
both messing up on the sarcasm
weirdly them attempting to speak English
for ten minutes is more entertaining
than us speaking English properly for
ten minutes it's crazy is it what I
loved about it was that every time they
spoke English they all seemed so excited
to get the words technical they just
seemed excited to expresses new and
exciting everything they said had an
exclamation mark at the end of it that's
inspiring and you know what also say
they're better than the Beatles they are
it's proven by facts and money they say
don't compare why because the Beatles
the remaining members the Beatles the
fool we're still alive or gonna be
really sad and just be like oh the BTS
homies did the better ones that's right
there's so much more talented than us
I believe Mick Jagger and Jimmy Page of
the Beatles both went on record saying
that well Mick Jagger is part of the
Monkees oh that's right I'm sorry
well you know you can't go on the
internet look like a dumbass John yeah
Trent Reznor sorry about it don't be
sorry don't apologize on my
I mean I thought this was a delightful
video it's exactly what it sounds like I
mean it's literally just a compilation
of any instance of them speaking English
no matter how prolonged or how
monosyllabic we get every I like how
kinetic and wacky these videos are
especially with like the crazy crash
zooms and stuff because it does enhance
the fun that can be had when you're
learning a language and I feel like the
pressures kind of off because it's
understood like RM has this covered and
the rest of us are learning so you know
we can do a little bit but it's yeah it
just seems like they're having so much
fun and English is a hard language to
learn so if anyone's having fun with it
that's inspiring to me let's rewind well
what is monosyllabic oh just you know
one syllable words that's a big word
just one syllable word just like the
fear of long words is a really long name
and I think the fear of palindromes if
I'm not mistaken has a palindrome names
I don't know if it's cookies and cream
that edited this video I'm assuming
cookies and cream did love cookies and
cream with a k' so cool that's what the
cake cool the way they did the flashing
of the words in the zooms actually drew
lead it'd enhance the comedy of it a lot
and there were times where I just
couldn't tell if they were jokingly
repeating it or if that was part of the
edits like what he was doing
shut up mouth no hey wait a minute shut
up Malfoy shut up shut up Malfoy
shut up muffled shots her mouth is RM
just repeating that a bunch cuz I could
believe that that'd be hilarious if it
was that one looked pretty authentic
yeah and that one was the ad I think my
favorite just because I'm fascinated by
accents
crossing over with language barriers and
stuff like that and so he did a pretty
good Harry Potter excerpt intere
prophecy now you grew up with friends
and RM loves friends and I grew up with
Harry Potter and clearly our M's a Harry
Potter fans so we should be friends with
him that's true we're I feel like sugar
is catching up to our
no on the English especially when RM was
like they don't speak English don't
listen to them they don't speak English
Rep but when sugars start speaking it
seem to just come from his heart
sometimes when they speak English I do
these body language things that John
does usually showing that they're
uncomfortable oh yeah they're talking
like when they're not feeling a little
unconfident but should nail that one
down he nailed it man nailed it he's
been studying in his off time you know
when no one else is looking cuz he wants
to be the leader who's gonna use Serb RM
there's gonna be a fight within the
group the group is going to split into
two it's gonna be a big deal now I mean
this from a completely heterosexual
standpoint
oh I'm speaking English this compilation
was one of the cutest things I've ever
seen it was adorable it was very capable
I will not say adorable I will say cute
that is the only word to describe it
okay all right it's very cute
BTS playing with puppies is adorable
that's adorbs okay all right as we can
agree on that geeking out over the
English turn ailing very cute that is
cute they are handsome and sexy I'm
speaking English is cute playing with
puppies is adorable we should do a
compilation of us speaking Korean and
lose our fan base we should do a
compilation of us speaking English oh
the hell will be a long compilation very
long just download all the videos and
make a super cuts to giant super cut
four hundred thousand hours long this is
our content add it on top of the
reaction for you guys I hope you've
enjoyed this part of the video riff we
could dissect all the word choices and
try and arrange them into some kind of
code one day we'll just be a reaction
channel that only reacts and calls it a
day instead of trying stuff out in the
commentary section
Natalie Doran thanks so much for
requesting this cookies-and-cream
subscribed there if you haven't heard
any of BTS as music yet what are you
doing with your life you're missing out
come check them out with me check out
John at our patreon page
where he is covering so much music and
so much cake cake cake pop let's the
ducked a couple of caves out there I'm
sorry
and Natalie I know you got some New
Year's goals in mind you say you want to
get in better shape or something doll
you look great as it is there's nothing
you need to change man just if anything
I'd say gain some lonesome weight more
cushion in the push and haven't heard
that phrase in years yeah man but that
doesn't apply to Bly to you that's
that's an appropriate become a
bodybuilder gain muscle if anything do
that yeah Jax is right now you're
looking perf which is short for perfect
annatto perfect Donato is the
superlative perfect so that's the word
you don't kind of demonstrate I speak
big words - ooh and ugly you said you
want to quit smoking
I wasn't even fully aware you smoked but
hey if you feel like quitting smoking to
better your health that's fine but just
know this if you're trying to lose
weight usually when people quit smoking
they gain weight so pick up a cocaine
habit to make up for it you guys just
like to keep it real here replace one
vice with another have you regretted
this yet Natalie